Затятий захисник журналістських свобод.
Таким позиціонував себе Володимир Зеленський рік тому,
коли нардеп від БПП Олег Барна вибухнув нецензурною лайкою на адресу журналіста "1+1".
Пі-пі-пі … на… пішов бігом
Зеленський тоді пропонував покарати таких депутатів челенджем ось з такою назвою…
Я думаю, що в лиці цього журналіста
він послав на три літери усіх представників медіа.
Тому, я думаю, буде справедливо, що я від усіх медіа виступлю з посланням у відповідь.Ідіть у сраку!
Але після перемоги ЗеКоманди ставлення до представник ів ЗМІ почало змінюватися.
Сам президент дозволяє собі про журналіста програми "Схеми" говорити так:
Де той хлопчик?
Голова Офісу президента Андрій Богдан дозволяє собі обіймати журналістку.
Новообрані депутати відверто хамлять пресі.
Зокрема Максим Бужанський, який сам є журналістом і блогером,
ось так ображає одну з журналісток.
Керівництво партії "Слуга народу" вибачилося за свого представника.
Сам же президент не реагує.
Навіть попри хвилю обурень з боку ЗМІ, багато з яких очікують відповідь на питання:
як буде ставитися влада до "слуг народу", які так поводяться.
Як тут не згадати: "Нам не дано предугадать, как наше слово отзовется".
Ці "тупі вівці" можуть ще зіграти злий жарт з президентом Зеленським  і його командою.
Чому він не реагує? Я думаю, що він будує абсолютно нову реальність, в якій йому зручно.
Більшетого, це найбільший ризик, коли він буде в такій оболонці - вакуумі.
А ви знаєте, що такі випадки були з президентом Януковичем,
коли йому будуть доносити інформацію, він буде героєм анекдотів,
але, насправді, не буде керувати всіма процесами.
В них реакції є, просто вони беруть не ту паузу,
напевно, для того, щоб соцмережі їм відповіли, як правильно себе поводити або ще щось.
Таке враження, що вони ніби маркер збирають,
який рівень вдоволення чи невдоволення та чи інша ситуація викликає, а потім вже готують відповідь.
Вони такі паузи роблять постійно.
Мені здається, що це стратегія, яка працює для нього,
як для політика,і він тримається успішної для себе стратегії.
Тут очевидно.
В принципі, для мене немає запитань, чому Зеленський так робить.
Очевидно, тому що це працює.
Він - людина з шоубізнесу, яка звикла до популярності і народної любові,
і ті поведінкові стратегії, які працюють, очевидно, що він буде їх притримуватися.
Тут питання до журналістської спільноти, як вона буде вибудовувати так само свою роботу з офісом.
В редакціях українських ЗМІ поки не вважають Володимира Зелененького
та його команду ворогами преси.
Втім, кажуть про певне занепокоєння стилем комунікації з пресою, який обрала влада.
ТелеканалZIKпісля того, якзмінився власник - тепер це Тарас Козак,
якого вважають близьким до кума Путіна Віктора Медведчука -
заявляє про повний ігнор командою Зе їхніх інформаційних запитів щодо інтерв'ю.
Поки щоЗеленський та його команда діє так само, як і попередня влада.
Вони залишали за собою право обирати, до кого прийти на інтерв’ю, кому відмовити.
Це жахлива практика.
В етері каналу "1+1", власником якого є олігарх Ігор Коломойський,
"слуги народу" з’являються частіше, ніж в інших медіа.
Коментувати, як каналу вдається така комунікація з владою, там відмовилися.
На Суспільному, яке фінансується з бюджету,
кажуть, що поки не мають великих труднощів з отриманням офіційної інформації.
Як каже журналістка та ведуча новин на Суспільному Олена Блізнякова,
ЗеКоманда працює трохи оперативніше, ніж команда Порошенка.
Втім, як і раніше, є проблеми із домовленостями
про конкретні терміни інтерв’ю з першою особою держави і щодо взагалі їх змісту.
Він може відповісти загальними фразами,він може не надати тобі жодної інформації.
Власне, попередній президент, з ним також можна було спілкуватися,
але ми дуже рідко зустрічалися от так от близько з президентом, щоб поставити питання.
Незважаючи на численні запити, ще ніхто з топ-менеджерів партії і сам президент
на інтерв’ю поки не прийшли, кажуть журналісти Громадського.
Як і експрезидент Порошенко в попередні 5 років.
Журналісти "Української правди" зазначають, що відкритість ЗеКоманди,
яка була, приміром, на початку передвиборчої кампанії, потроху дає збій.
І журналістів багатьох видань все більше непокоїть,
заява голови Офісу президента Андрія Богдана про те,
що владі для спілкування з народом преса не потрібна.
Мовляв, ЗеКоманда непогано спілкується з населенням і через соцмережі.
Я думаю, що люди в будь-якому разі не будуть спиратися виключно на соцмережі
та спілкування у вигляді якихось опитувань чи ще чогось - спілкувань картиночками і мемасиками.
Як бивони не ставилися до журналістів, просто виходити в соцмережі напряму до народу…
Вони не напряму до народувиходять, тому що з народом не спілкуються.
Коли на них дивиться журналіст і задає ці запитання - це одна історія.
Зовсім інша історія, коли ти виходиш, ну не знаю, стилі Путіна на гарячу телефону лінію
чи-то онлайнконференцію і обираєш з1000 запитаньсамі красиві, які тобі подобаються.
Хочеться зазначити, що президент і українська влада не може обирати:
чи потрібні журналісти чи не потрібні.
Це одна з засадничих речей для демократії.
Очевидно, що ця співпраця з журналістами почалася явно не з того тону,
явно не з того, з чого могли б складатися відносини якоїсь взаємоповаги і довіри.
Журналісти сподіваються, що президент України все-таки особисто відповість на запитання преси
і щодо поведінки новобраних депутатів, і ще на купу інших конкретних запитань,
які накопичилися щодо внутрішньої і зовнішньої політики.
Поки Зеленський жодної великої пресконференції не провів.
Очікується, що це може статися незабаром. На перші 100 днів президенства.